bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo
sull'attacco dei giganti minchia che non
è cazzuto perché mette ho scelto questo
videogame perché praticamente è tratto
da un anime che dai che a sua volta è
tratto da un manga capiente che a me
piace un casino non pensavo che avessero
fatto fiducia comi che ci sono rimasti
in una maniera incredibile
non vedo l'ora di provarlo anormale
difficile anormale mettiamo un normale
che già stato impedito così tra l'altro
sono e mezzo in cinese va bene se ne
frega facciamo helen che il personaggio
principale alla prima i ragazzi vi
spiego
ci sono amp si parte che figurano che ti
odio rega aiuto con minchia quanto sei
figo ragazzi e non lo è ma lui non al
bene quando riguardo guardalo ragazzi
c'è il mondo mi fa una pippa in poche
parole lega i giganti si ammazzano
colpendola alla nuca dietro il collo
sempre se non ti mangiano prima dove
devo colpirli dietro al collo tipo così
non lo fa eco infatti se ti becco
davanti non si fanno un cazzo perdevate
evento vede [ __ ] addio beccati
questo la beffa con tu non hai un bene
tu non hai ballamy stronzo non sono
forse un po cioppa [ __ ]
ecco come non detto ragazzi è
impossibile ci sono due miliardi di
comandi come cazzo si fa una cosa
assurda
c come come cazzo faccia farmaco si
vabbè dai guardalo
minchia [ __ ]
ma cerchietto pasco deficiente è una
inciampato su una buccia di banana
probabilmente non lo so che cazzo fatto
che se signora karmica sei un figo della
madonna tuffate falsa
[Musica]
alla ragazza posso fare non è non ci
voglio credere che non riesco a farmene
anche una donna che te la infilo nel
naso la posso fare ora di smetterla di
muovere come mai si gira i pugni da solo
almeno uno cazzo dai vi prego non è così
sì sì ma devi morire se sei cazz e
[ __ ] sommesso mezzana sono
soddisfatto perché almeno una e siamo a
due hanno preso ragazzi mi è venuto da
solo è questo data gnam
la situazione si sta facendo leggermente
di merda ma non importa
vedo se riesco a far sì va beh in mezzo
foto la merda bravo così sono un vero
che cosa ha fatto
guarda lo guarda lo è lo sterminatore di
giganti a prezzi almeno uno l'ho fatto
fuori ragazzi una soddisfazione quando
ne faccio fuori uno perché è impossibile
guardali morire devi morire e devi
morire ma chi cazzo sei caparezza
ma come fai ad avere i capelli così raga
qualcuno c'ha voglia di spiegarmi che
problemi mentali già sto tizio smettila
rimasto rubarti con quella roba lì fermo
la cosa che allora guarda lì che brutto
che sei madonna ecco meglio così
cavani napoli ora io uccido i giganti
picchia che cazzo fatto ragazzi sta cosa
non riuscirà mai più
guardavo fuggire lo fuggire lo fuggire
fuggi fuggi
si ok ho fatto appena in tempo mi
stavano stuprando il 25 non fatti fuori
due nostri ragazzi la battaglia più
titanica che abbia mai visto in vita mia
guardale si no [ __ ] piena
battaglia di assoluta non hai combattuto
sono in tensione cazzo se tu muori fuori
stronzo scappa scappa veloce ragazzi ce
la facciano fatta mi sento un dio mi
sento un dio mi che ha ammazzato un
gigante in una maniera che non uscirà
mai più
qua di cazzo sono ok dal tagliandata
nessuno da tagliando di morire devi
morire e devi mori guardali che se
schiatta ma porca pozze se è morto
d'artagnan è morto dato che ha in sé ma
di rimangono 31 ce la possiamo fare ha
così scoreggia perfetto non già questo
non lo sapeva anaci al turbo o capita
fanno bene i fagioli la mattina a dirlo
è la potenza è tutta nostra che hanno
mancato di brutto vasta suo braccio che
non è sconsigliati bravo così ragazzi mi
sento un di ogni watt e ragazzi mandiamo
che io io non ho fatto né allora ti do i
soldi per la merenda non buttarmi così
ragazzi e bullismo a questo [ __ ]
non ci si può neanche più avvicinare qui
raga la gente è diventato ma guarda lì
per caso di salto ha fatto che non lo so
perché ma chissene forte domandare a
massacrare gigante guardalo in ma
neanche superman come a marzo non
mancano ma non importa
questo è peggio di caparezza 6 capelli
che mi piaci finisci dentro non ci esci
più madonna madonna che tattica d'oro
confonde lo confonde e così confuso da
colpirsi da solo ma mi spiace perché
sono ci sono dei titani che sono uguali
a d'artagnan mezzi più incazzati
storica porca [ __ ] miss aperto tutto
tranne quello che dovevo fare
sì sì bravo bravo no non sono ancora
vivo sono più lo vivo come cazzo lo zio
ragazzi sono vivo sono come cazzo fatto
ragazzi ho schivato 12 miliardi di cose
non so come me lo spieghi tu d'artagnan
a chi ve l'ha
forse questo mi ha tirato una testata
mia mancato e mi ha spinto contro un
altro gigante che sto per uccidere devi
morire perché non sto morendo che mi
stanno qui si stanno buttando addosso in
cinquemila e non mi vecchia 1 ma perché
si sono buttati addosso in 500 cosa fa
quello ragazzi vola buona aiuto hanno
imparato a volare cazzo adesso sì che
sono cazzi nostri
ecco infatti ragazzi e provate a
cambiare personaggio vediamo che cazzo
sv oa perfetto siamo nella foresta e
pensare questo gioco ci sono anche i
boss ma io non riesco a battere questi
come cazzo faccio abbattere il boss mica
che cosa sto facendo
la venisse mosse brutto stronzo leve di
ragazzi che cazzo sta facendo quel dio
che cosa brutta praga mi sembra la
bambina di the ring ed inaspettati ma
che cazzo sta facendo ma si sta fermo
che devo vedere che cazzo fatto il tizio
non ho capito che cazzo sta facendo ad
ammazzare chi se ne fotte
gliel'ho infilato nei già frase ma io
voglio andare un attimo a capire che
cazzo sta facendo quello che strisciava
prima se riesco a di beccarlo ma perché
non l'ho mica capito mi chiamo ne sto
volando madonna mi sento superman
comunque una nota eccolo lì perfetto
l'ho trovato l'ho capito che stai
cercando i tuoi occhiali da sole lo so
non so no fermo fermo fermo tino aiutare
io ti voglio aiutare cazzo ok
mica sono scappati in una magnetica ciao
tutto a posto
come stai fuori strada ti sembra di
cavalcare un torero maledizione
no no no no no è uno dei pochi
videogiochi veramente c'è una difficoltà
in mondo a giocare perché minchia i
comandi sono impossibili adesso che ho
detto sta cosa faccio una strage mo
basta non dovevo dirlo con che i ragazzi
l'ho fatto più che altro perché mi
piaceva l'anima e quindi ci ho provato
mi sembra che lui portate che abbiamo
fatto il culo a tartaglia ma anche
ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto come al
solito lasciato un commento mi piace
anche al face à face book e come non i
video trovate nella descrizione sense
enac rischi fiscali ci vediamo al
prossimo video e le ragazze